there is always this rush of adrenaline
that emotions are always on the
surface
I have had two falls several attacks
that is part of the risk that one assumes in
a work for the conservation of
the species that is found
[Music]
my name is  alexander blanco márquez i
am a veterinary doctor i specialize in
medicine and conservation of the
harpy eagle in venezuela
of a species that is considered threatened
within the red list of the
world union for the conservation of
nature due to habitat loss
and indiscriminate hunting
for me it is the most majestic branch of the
forest its claws are 15 centimeters
larger than those of a brown bear or its
wingspan its size strength
intelligence that gives it a
formidable characteristic to be
considered one of the most impressive animals
[Applause]
[  Music]
basically we climb these trees that
are on average between 40 and 45
meters
[Music]
we capture the pigeon in e  he nest and
we lower it to avoid a possible attack from
the parents
[Music
] first of all we put an
identification ring on it for ourselves and it creeps
into space it is a certain place
future deception we measure its total length its
wingspan and other important measurements
for the  studying the animal is a
dangerous job we are talking about
entering the domain of this
eagle being in good health on
several occasions suffered from falls from
trees I fell from a height of 38 meters in
free fall
I was literally locked on the floor
not for  there many people say well,
most of them keep climbing but well that
's my job and this is my commitment to
myself in the first place if
we weren't crazy they wouldn't
know much about the eagle
today we have realized that the
essence of our work
mainly it is to create awareness among the
people of the rural communities
where they cohabit with the year
[Music]
[Applause]
if the p  people learn to know
protein protect they are preserved
we have worked with our nails
but now we are seeing the result
of our project we do not have a total
of approximately 105 nests and that
means that in a certain way
the work that has been done in
the  rural schools despite all
the difficulties we keep
going
[Music]